many people have asked me what was
happening when we got the call actually
you know with it's five o'clock in the
morning and so we were asleep the
telephone is on my wife's side of the
bed so she picked it up and said some
call it may basically wasn't quite clear
and gave it to me and my first reaction
was that when you get calls at five
thirty in the morning that's usually bad
news maybe that our son was sick I have
a daughter in Israel we hear that
something has happened there but little
by little I discovered what it actually
was that was a full phone call from
Sweden announcing the Nobel Prize and I
was you know very pleased by that to be
quite honest many people have said that
I should have had the Nobel Prize maybe
30 years ago and so actually for a while
until fairly recently I used to sort of
watch at the right time usually whenever
we spent half of our time in Europe and
half our time in the US and if you in
Europe of course the Nobel prizes and
announced that a more decent time you
know around eleven thirty or so and I
used to watch but the last few years so
decided well I've sort of given up and
so it was a pleasant surprise